lingering on a terrace is one of life's
pleasures for many people in france
but soon only those with a covid pass
showing that they are fully vaccinated
or have a negative pcr test will be able
to enjoy the experience
staff will have to check customers
passes something this restaurant owner
says is unfair
we consider that this is not our job
to check your id and your covet pass we
understand
that this is certainly something
necessary
but we are not policemen
the past which is now mandatory in
cinemas theatres and museums will be
extended to large shopping centres
and some transport the french government
hopes it will reduce
health risks and encourage people to get
vaccinated
be in no doubt our goal as always is to
take measures that are proportional to
the health situation
to guarantee public freedoms while
assuring the sanitary security of our
citizens
the french president emmanuel macron
announced the new covid pass rules last
week and since then
there has been a surge in the number of
people booking vaccination appointments
within days nearly 4 million people had
signed up for their
first jab i don't think we should have
two opposite groups
the vaccinated and the non-vaccinated i
think it's up to each person to do what
they want to do
the past made us to act now as we had
planned waiting until august to get
vaccinated
the pass is dividing opinion these
protesters in paris on sunday said the
government's trying to force people to
get vaccinated
by eroding their rights
people should be given the freedom to
choose whether or not they want to be
vaccinated so it's more democratic
some scientists say that france is in a
fourth wave
fueled by the highly contagious delta
covid variant
the government says that the pass will
be necessary for as long as the virus is
a threat
although some regard it as
anti-democratic
opinion polls suggest that two-thirds of
people in france
support it as a way of hopefully
avoiding another lockdown
natasha butler al jazeera paris